[Music]
when the first astrazeneca doses arrived
in ireland
last month the country's health minister
tweeted this video
hailing it as a big day today his
department suddenly pulled the vaccine
in a surprise statement this morning the
irish department of health here in
dublin
announced the suspension of the
astrazeneca vaccine after reports from
norway of a small number of adults who
had received the dose there
developing blood clot issues although
the irish authorities stress that no
conclusive link has yet been established
for now at least the astrazeneca vaccine
has been withdrawn
here in ireland in a statement
astrazeneca said that
an analysis of our safety data from more
than 17 million doses of vaccine
administered
has shown no evidence of an increased
risk
some experts have urged the public not
to read too much
into the suspension i think we have to
bear in mind in science
that correlation isn't causation we're
basing this on reports from scandinavia
we have to look at again say the british
data where millions of doses have been
given and we haven't seen
an elevation in these events but it's
still better to be cautious
and the decision today has been made
over and even over abundance of caution
ireland isn't the first country to take
action denmark
norway and iceland have also temporarily
halted astrazeneca vaccinations to
investigate the reports
austria banned doses from a particular
batch after a person was hospitalized
with pulmonary embolism after being
vaccinated
italy estonia and other countries then
followed suit
astrazeneca vaccine has had some quite
poor press
in the last few months most of it i
think has been unjustified
and it will make it more difficult for
people to
accept the vaccine it will put people
off and if it does that as it
almost certainly will it will lead to
more people getting ill
more people getting severely ill and
more people dying
irish authorities are awaiting further
information from the european medicines
agency
and are hopeful the astrazeneca
suspension will only last for a week
but that's a week when tens of thousands
of irish people
had hoped to receive their first dose
stephen murphy's sky news in dublin